fallar a la saad se dio ante la presión
internacional para que ingrese más ayuda
humanitaria a las zonas en control
Rebelde a las hadas aceptó que Dos
cruces fronterizos con Turquía fueran
usados para recibir ayudas por un
período de tres meses una decisión que
se dio luego de la reunión del jefe de
ayuda de Naciones Unidas y el presidente
sirio en Damasco y que fue informada en
una reunión a Puerta cerrada entre los
integrantes del Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU Naciones Unidas ha denunciado en
repetidas ocasiones que el poco acceso a
Siria hace que el proceso de ayuda sea
lento y complicado abrir estos puntos de
cruce facilitar el acceso humanitario
acelerar las aprobaciones de Visas y
facilitar los viajes entre los centros
permitirá que ingrese más ayuda y que
sea más rápido debido al conflicto
bélico presente en Siria desde 2011 el
Noroeste del país está dividido una
región que se pelea el control entre el
régimen autoritario de la Sad y Los
Rebeldes y que hace que el acceso a la
zona sea especialmente difícil desde
2014 la ONU se ha limitado a usar solo
un cruce fronterizo para ayudar a las
personas devastadas por la guerra
ayuda también llega desde otros países
Jordania no ha detenido el envío de
caravanas de ayudas vía terrestre hoy un
convoy de 14 camiones se dirige a la
media luna roja Siria a través de la
frontera terrestre y las organizaciones
de las naciones que trabajan en las
áreas afectadas y se convoy contiene
medicamentos suministros médicos y
equipos quirúrgicos que son necesarios
en tales circunstancias así como
alimentos y materiales diversos
y convoy katari también estaba a la
espera del visto bueno de Damasco para
ingresar con ayudas con la apertura se
espera que más países aporten a la
asistencia humanitaria